you know what we can and social right it
Chang and and Siri hooked that into Siri
now what can Siri do about that you know
already there's a service called gobi go
that you can say I'm here um where's all
the hiking trails around here right you
know and it's cool it shows it on a map
you know um realtors.com had a map where
you just look at the city oh I want to
live in that part of the city you Circle
it and it shows all the houses available
in that part of the city right you know
and you know and then you hook that into
a calendar you start saying okay I I
have five houses to look at I can't do
all five today let's do two today well
that's a calendar yeah you know let's do
three tomorrow yeah and the calendar
then has to get the realtor you know
could talk to my realtor and say hey I
got to look at houses tomorrow can you
make you know these three houses happen
well that's calendar and so there's
calendar underneath there might not be
the right you might not look at the grid
but your the data is there and the
assistant like Siri that you're talking
to is going to make the deal with you
know she'll talk to my you know the Siri
app will talk to my realtor app make a
deal and find out that she's available
or not you
know let's talk about privacy for two
minutes because it's something that's
kind of comes up um one of the things
that we certainly notice and we've
talked about is that you know the valley
has a very unique perspective on that
and as you move to the Northeast there's
a different viewpoint but as an example
I just want to kind of start off with
how many four square friends have you
got 9,000 M okay and 3,000 on goala
Twitter 130,000 Facebook uh
1,700 and then 11,000 on my public page
so you're living your life in public
very much your autoresponder got your
cell number your your home address
hasn't run has it you this is the this
is the weird side people are afraid of
[__] that they don't know yeah but once
they know it's like why didn't you know
you get really good phone calls and if
you get a Spam call you hang up on it's
like it's not that big a deal and I
don't get that much stuff I my email
actually I get far more spam and
intrusive kind of things on my email
than I do on my phone people are
unlikely to pick up the phone after they
receive that autoresponder and say hi
Robert I want to talk about these kinds
of things yeah it's something about
voice is like I'm only going to call him
if I have something really interesting
to say with all of that kind of living
in public is it ever presented kind of
you ever feel like people are crossing
the line with you
um not because of that
uh I can't walk around an exhibit hall
at a Tech conference and not get costed
you know right and that but that has
nothing to do with the fact that I
checked in on for square they don't they
don't accost me because they check in on
Four Square they check in because oh
they's Scoville I want to picture my
product 100% but they're looking for you
once they see on Four Square check in
right I I don't haven't noticed really
the different you know and personally if
I'm checking in a tech event I'm okay
with it anyway I'm I know I know what's
going to happen yeah right and but it
doesn't happen people don't come out to
where I am you know they just see it's
very weird people aren't aren't aren't
using these tools to really get to that
level of stocking you hear a lot about
it but I think it's paranoid yeah I I
can see the fear and I I'm actually
worried about other things
so if we all live in public and I can
watch you all day
long now I can see patterns in your life
that you might not even know exist and
the credit card I talked with somebody
who works at Visa he says well he says
they can predict somebody's going to get
a divorce a year before they're
div because your spending habits change
and you you start doing things with your
money to protect yourself against an
impending bad event in your life and so
if and and the CIA is doing this right
how do they catch terrorists they're
looking for patterns and if you have
enough data and have enough people
passing information back and forth you
can see those pattern you know if uh if
a rack space executive keeps flying to a
certain company and keeps go visiting
there you can start saying that guy is
making a business deal or being acquired
or something like that right changing
companies or changing companies right so
now now you start calling all of his
friends at work and going why is he
always visiting Amazon or what you know
and wow we didn't have that pattern
before uh you know that was opaque to us
now it now it could be very visible
right and um so we're we're going to
have different privacy concern in the
future than we have today you know it's
a little weird for old people to put
this data in right because it's like we
didn't put our medical history of and we
don't talk about that you know Steve
Jobs didn't want to share his kidney
problem or his liver problem right but
in the future you're going to put that
up on your blog so that the best doctor
in the world is going to see that or
somebody who has the same problem as you
and says hey I did the research and
here's the best doctor and here's the
the newest Medical Science and here's
the drug you know you better check this
out and ask your doctor about this stuff
you know and it's true I I interviewed a
surgeon he said the knowledge and
medical stuff is changing so fast he
can't he's a Stanford you know uh a lung
surgeon who is like one of the best in
the world and he can't he says
everything he learned in medical school
is completely obsolete 30 years ago
right and so now he uses an iPhone to
keep track of what's going on in the
world you know and he looks up your
symptoms on the iPhone to make sure that
the sign didn't change in the last 24
hours CU some some doctor in Harvard you
know or somewhere else in the world you
know discovered a new treatment or
discovered a new you know way to deal
with this you know so so let me you know
this comes back to too information too
much information in some ways right we
see part of our responsibility is these
this data flows into your calendars to
help contextualize it right you got
these huge pipes out there you want to
bring in a Twitter stream it's
meaningless unless you contextualize it
yeah you have all people must just have
this flood of data coming in can you
talk for two minutes about how you deal
with that I mean as an example I get
your autoresponder and it's clear
there's no way you're responding to
every email you have too much else going
on in your life no especially if I do
interesting stuff like this um I I look
at it as surf you know it's like it's
like the sea is really wet and there's a
lot of water there and we don't care we
go surfing you know and we don't try to
drink all the water we don't try to
understand it all we just surf the wave
you know and and so I a river of crap is
coming through my life right right now
as we sit there's a river of crap going
through my screen and um when I get back
online I'll dive in and swim for a
little while and then get out and I I
don't feel guilty anymore that I can't
do it all right um are you comfortable
that you're surfacing the most Salient
the most
interesting I am always worried that I'm
going to miss something but on the other
hand I Flipboard you know and it was a
stupid little pitch I I posted the pitch
that they sent me it's like we have
something you think we think you should
see and I had no clue who the company oh
really that's the way they approached
you did you not then connect Ashton to
them was that yeah but that was later
that was after I saw the product and I
got excited by it it's like I don't you
know the way I mean I'm looking for
Serendipity and so that caught my eye
it's like oh here's somebody who is
interested in I so I in my life I have I
in in my professional life I have these
things called battlefronts that I U that
I'm passionate about things like iPads
and 3D cameras right 3D technology right
or um uh you know iPhones versus Android
that's that's interesting to me iPhone
versus Nokia over you know iPhone versus
so if you if you pitch me something on
one of those story arcs or
battlefronts I'm going to be more
interested than if you pitch me an
Enterprise app that works with Exel 2
right and and so yeah they pitched me
and it's like I it it had keywords like
iPad social media you know and they they
were they were reading me and it's like
okay what's up with this coming that was
a different kind of pitch than I've seen
so so I had to go and see him and of
course like oh yeah that's
cool um but anyway I I'm chasing those
kind of Serendip experiences I think
that's why I liked Four Square so much
four square is Serendipity around Place
M uh and Serendipity around people so um
in Paris I have no idea where I am and I
don't really know what I want to do um
I'll check in and see did anybody leave
any tips and you know one of the tips
there's a real world one of the tips was
the best French Pates right around the
corner it's like I would never have
searched for bench best French baby but
I found it and it was an EXT ordinary
French bakery you know and when I get
into Atlanta I checked in at a
restaurant I said try the fried bacon
it's not on the menu you wouldn't have
found it on the menu if you just read
the menu you had to read four square and
find this little tip that somebody left
you know and it's Serendipity and it
makes your experience better and gives
you stories to tell your friends and
isn't the obligation to Move It from
Serendipity to real intelligence though
so that you're kind of ensuring that
flow I don't know because you know what
if it's real intelligence then everybody
goes there mhm and then it's not cmore
it's not you didn't find the piece of
gold on the street you know by running
across sure sure I mean you know four
square beyond the checkin has this
really rich repository of metadata right
and that's really what you're talking
about if you look at it in terms of the
individual you were talking about
patterns before not only you seeing time
and place but you're seeing interests
right um yeah eventually I I mean I
would love to see uh I would love to see
a system where I could say show me all
the Half Moon Bay restaurants but only
show the reviews written by people who
have been to four barbecue places or
more get rid of everybody else because I
want to see what the meat eaters think I
I want some meat you know right and I I
I don't care what the Fish Eaters think
and I don't care what the veggies you
know the vegans think because they're
not meat eaters they don't know what the
best meat places so I want to just study
what the the med say and I I can't do
that today you know but eventually I
think we will be able to they all these
you know all these location systems are
building that kind of database and you
could chunk it out like that one of the
things that we see the the calendar of
the future to do it's actually actually
even shorter than the future but um is
about helping you understand how you're
using your time and then giving you
recommendations so like a match model
where you're studying CR credit card
exactly hey you you went to sushi
restaurant
this many times and you're spending too
much money right and that's part of why
we first first the First Fundamental is
being able to aggregate all the data
from all your calendars but also from
for Square from you know any feed that
you may have and then from there giving
you analytics you know so that you can
start doing some really cool stuff
that's Linda Stone and I have been
talking about that and she asked me how
how do I U manage my attention not
manage my time cuz managing time is like
you know what am I going to do for the
next hour right but how do I manage um
how do I manage to do this you know how
do I make enough time and I I thought
back and it's like I was at Food the
first food camp and I you know I
eventually got kicked out and no I'm
back
again but I told him rightly this I said
you know what the first two were so
magical I wanted to do that every day of
my life that that was sort of I want to
live a food Camp life every day of my
life and be interviewing or talking with
some geek who's changing the world yeah
you know and have that experience so
that was it I I set up I I'm going to do
an interview every day of my life I you
know um and it'll be an hour or or two
hours or something like that and that'll
be my first thing I put on the
calendar and I'll try to focus all my
energy into making that happen right um
and that's hard to communicate with a
calendar you know because it just is
it's it's hard to say oh yeah I got my
life directive done
today right you know and especially
tongle me actually works against you
because people can if if you let your
because I started putting my tongle me
out there I I actually pulled my tongue
me a little bit back yeah because people
would just take every freaking hour of
your day and for stupid for stuff that I
like that's not a that's not a food Camp
experience that's right that's like a St
stupid company come
on want two hours on top of it right
well or they worse I I don't even care
about that cuz every once in a while I
see a company that I think is stupid and
then it turns out to be brilliant right
but they'll there'll be a company here
and a company here and they'll take the
45 minutes in between I'm like I got to
travel between here and here you know so
then I had to start blocking things out
and and that but it
also I like uh thinking about you know
the the pacing of a week the day and and
if I'm letting other people be in
control of my calendar I can't do that
and they'll take every available hour
because they want my
attention so I got to remember oh I need
to exercise I need to spend time with
the family and I'm not doing enough for
that are you scheduling that stuff just
out of curiosity I well I I made it so
that tungle can't take more than a
couple hours a day so people only can
have a few hours
um um and yeah I'm blocking morning time
out I don't do I don't do anything in
the morning usually um but yeah I even
stock you guys in a 10 which which I
appreciate I usually don't but that's
why I sort of keep like before 11 open
once so I can sleep and and do some
exercise and stuff like that so being to
sleep you roll over in the morning
what's the first thing that you kind of
grab and what's the first thing you look
at or